the next two years are going to be very
uncomfortable for Donald Trump and his
criminal cronies and the investigations
are going to get started
rapidly when Democrats take over the
house in January of 2019 the day after
the midterms I gave you a list of
possible areas of investigation for
Democrats to look at when they're sworn
in and take control of the house in
January and Democrats now are telling us
which are going to be the top priorities
and if you think that Donald Trump
hasn't liked having I don't know three
major investigations into his
administration and family just wait to
see what he's going to do when there are
a dozen or more simultaneous
investigations subpoenas lawsuits and
everything that we're going to see
starting in January of 2019 let's start
from the top
soon-to-be chairman of the House
Intelligence Committee Adam shift Adam
Schiff rather says that an investigation
into Trump's financial ties to Saudi
Arabia are going to be part of an
upcoming investigation this is going to
expose a whole slew of conflicts of
interest and even possibly
constitutional emoluments problems for
Trump and all of this escalated recently
because of Donald Trump siding with
Saudi Arabia over the killing of
journalist Jamal khashoggi that's number
one number two Schiff has made it clear
that now that Devin Nunez is out of the
way in the House Intelligence Committee
and Democrats are going to be back in
control the house is going to
reinvigorate that Trump Russia probe
which the House Intelligence Committee
ended what did they say Pat no evidence
of wrongdoing and just no reason to even
interview all the witnesses and no
problem with Devin Nunez running to
trump to tell him what they were doing
that one's coming back and I'm very much
looking forward to that
well it's certainly worth looking into I
just think that at this point any major
findings in the Trump Russia situation
is going to come from the Muller probe
as opposed to the House or Senate
Intelligence Committee investigations
but I take your point and I certainly
welcome it Democrats
in the House Oversight Committee are
going to look into Ivanka Trump's use of
private email for government business
which might violate federal law but her
emails right that's actually going to be
part of a bigger investigation into
private email use it turns out I mean
it's just so absurd it's been projection
after projection after projection in
this administration after all the talk
about Hillary's emails there's now going
to be a broad investigation into private
email use by Jared Kushner and Ivanka
and former chief of staff Reince Priebus
and it's a whole long list of Trump
staffers that have been using private
email there are five investigations
planned just into Donald Trump's
completely in over her head Secretary of
Education Betsy DeVos five committees
all of which will soon be controlled by
Democrats have elements of Betsy devices
reign of terror that they want to look
into this includes Veterans Affairs this
includes House Appropriations it's a
long list so this is just the tip of the
iceberg
this could cause Trump to become even
more erratic even more unhinged you can
even imagine that and I'm not going to
give you the full list of possible
investigations again but the important
piece is for everybody saying things
like Dems should play nice so that
things can get done or Democrats should
focus on bipartisanship have you
forgotten the Obama years if you don't
hit them as hard as possible and go
after them for everything that they've
done I'm not saying trumped-up charges
I'm saying go after them for what
they've done or what we suspect they've
done if you don't do that you lose
because they attack either way all the
time okay the idea that now they're
going to play nice if Democrats just
play nice it's ridiculous okay whoever
becomes House Speaker Republicans are
going to attack whatever Democrats try
to do on health care or on daca or on
climate change Republicans are going to
attack they will never hold the other
side to the same standard
Hillary will bomb Syria if you will
sir Trump bomb Syria oh they deserved it
great show of strength by Trump
definitely not a Russian puppet Hillary
Clinton will use cronyism to get out of
all her crimes
Trump literally firing people to
obstruct an investigation into his
potential crime oh well the
investigation was a witch-hunt hillary
and humi Abaddon's use of private emails
should put them in prison
Oh Kushner and Ivanka and Reince Priebus
they all use private email well listen
those rules are very hard to stick to
and it's all just a witch-hunt
if we're lucky 2019 is going to be a
nightmare for Donald Trump and if his
behavior since the midterms is any
indication it seems that he knows it it
seems that it's going to be a tough
couple of years for him and I'm looking
forward to it I hope you are too